Muchos se preguntan si es posible hacer
compatible el Islam con la democracia y
los derechos humanos.
Lo cierto es que hay muy pocos ejemplos
para ser optimistas, incluso en Turquía
donde la separación entre Iglesia y
Estado está garantizada por la propia
constitución parecen estar dando pasos
cada vez más rápido hacia lo que
sería una teocracia islámica.
Sin embargo hay un país que escapa de
esta tendencia y ese país es: Túnez.
Esta república de poco más de 10 millones
de habitantes fue el lugar donde
empezaron las llamadas "Primaveras
Árabes" -que nunca he entendido porque
las llaman primaveras cuando en realidad
empezaron en enero.
Lo cierto es que fue aquí concretamente
en la ciudad de Sidi Bouzid donde un
frutero de 26 años se quemó a lo bonzo
en una protesta en frente de un edificio
del gobierno.
Así es como comenzó una revolución
que se extendió por todos los países
del norte de África.
El resto de la historia ya la conocemos:
en Egipto consiguieron derrocar a su
dictador pero al final han terminado
volviendo a otra dictadura militar
igual o peor que la que tenían antes.
Libia es un estado fallido con riesgo de
caer en manos del integrismo islámico y
de Siria mejor no hablar.
Sin embargo, Túnez es la excepción que
confirma la regla.
Tras deponer a su dictador Abidine Ben
Alí, los tunecinos redactaron una
constitución que reconoce la libertad
de expresión y la libertad de culto.
No sólo eso además el 20 por ciento de
los escaños del parlamento tunecino
están ocupados por mujeres, lo que
supone un paso de gigante en esta
región. Y precisamente por eso
Túnez se ha convertido en una de los
principales objetivos del DAESH que ya
lleva asesinados a más de 73 personas
en tres atentados terroristas.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿será capaz de
sobrevivir la democracia tunecina? Puede
llegar a convertirse en un modelo para
el resto de países islámicos. Hoy vamos
a responder a esa pregunta y además
vamos a hablar del rol que tienen la
Unión Europea en toda esta historia que
puede ayudar o dinamitar todo el proceso
democrático en Túnez. Pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de perspectiva
histórica.
En 1955 Túnez se independizó
de Francia, al igual que casi todos los
países de la región, Túnez
se apuntó al llamado socialismo
árabe o panarabismo, que es un cóctel
ideológico que mezcla economía
planificada, líderes autoritarios muy
carismáticos y por supuesto secularismo.
Incluso si me lo permitís una actitud
bastante beligerante con la religión
especialmente con el islam.
Esta corriente ideológica fue muy
popular en la zona y nos ha dado a
líderes tan populares como Muamar el
Gadafi en Libia o Nasser en Egipto.
En el caso de Túnez su presidente
sería este señor que vemos aquí que
se llamaba Habib ben Alí Burguiba. Por hacer un
resumen, su gobierno estuvo marcado por
el clientelismo, la corrupción y
continuas devaluaciones de la divisa
tunecina -el dinar- que terminaron por dar
al traste con la economía tunecina. El
resultado: que en 1987 y con una crisis
financiera bestial aprovechando que
Bourguiba estaba en el hospital
recuperándose de un infarto, su primer
ministro le robó el sillón
presidencial y se hizo con el gobierno
en lo que llaman "el golpe de estado
médico". No hubo el más mínimo atisbo
de violencia, es más cuando Bourguiba
salía del hospital, Abidine Ben Alí le
mandó a una residencia de lujo con
médicos y enfermeros que pudieran
cuidar de él.
No sólo eso además cuentan que hasta el
día de su muerte
Ben Alí le visitaba frecuentemente para
ver cómo estaba.
Vamos que aquello fue un golpe de estado
pero con cariño. Y os preguntaréis, ¿qué
hizo Abidine Ben Alí como
gobernante de Túnez? Durante su
presidencia prometió varias veces que
tras día la democracia al país y lo
cierto es que convocó elecciones en
varias ocasiones. El problema es que los
partidos políticos que quisieran
presentarse necesitaban como mínimo 30
firmas de miembros del propio gobierno
de Ben Alí.
Esto significa que en muchos casos la
única candidatura que podía
presentarse a unos comicios era ¡o
sorpresa! la de su propio partido.
Gracias a esta peculiar interpretación
de la democracia,
Ben Alí se mantuvo en el poder durante
más de 23 años. 23 años que por
supuesto estuvieron marcados por la
misma corrupción y clientelismo a la
que los tunecinos estaban ya tan
acostumbrados.
Sin embargo hay una cosa que sí que le
tenemos que reconocer a nuestro amigo
Abidine Ben Alí y fue su pragmatismo a la
hora de pensar la política económica.
Desde el primer momento entendió que
tenía que abrirse a la inversión
extranjera y permitir que empresas de
otros países pudieran establecerse en
su territorio.
Así es como llegaron varias cadenas
hoteleras atraídas por el buen clima y
las playas de Túnez. Y así es como el
turismo se convirtió en la primera
industria de Túnez seguida del cultivo
del olivo. Y quedaros con esto de los
olivos porque luego vamos a hablar de
ello.
Lo cierto es que durante estos 20 años
los tunecinos multiplicaron su riqueza
por tres y de hecho en el año 2010
Túnez recibió a seis millones de
turistas que es la mitad de lo que
recibe su vecina Egipto con la
diferencia de que egipto tiene las
pirámides y nueve veces más población.
Quedaros con esta cifra porque también
es muy importante.
Túnez es un país de diez millones de
habitantes que ha llegado a recibir seis
millones de turistas en solamente un
año.
¿Y por qué hago tanto énfasis en este punto?
Pues porque los turistas no solamente dejan
dinero en el país sino también
cultura.
De repente, en Túnez se convirtió en
adobo normal ver a mujeres occidentales
pasear sin tener la cabeza cubierta, a
parejas homosexuales dándose la mano
por la calle o incluso a gente bebiendo
alcohol. Es decir ningún otro país de
la zona ha estado tan expuesto a otras
formas de vida como lo ha estado Túnez.
Y por eso si eres uno de esos españoles
que se ha emborrachado alguna vez en un
hotel tunecino durante un viaje de fin
de carrera,
enhorabuena puedes decir que pusiste tu
granito de arena para abrir la sociedad
tunecina.
Gracias a eso han podido ocurrir cosas
como ésta:
En el año 2010 la economía tunecina
estaba 'on fire' pero sin embargo la tasa
de desempleo estaba por encima del 12%.
A todo esto hay que sumarle los
escándalos de corrupción y los abusos
de poder por parte del gobierno de Ben
Alí que no se publicaron en la prensa
local
pero sí en los periódicos extranjeros,
incluidos El País en España. Y esto
motivó varias protestas en distintas
ciudades.
Probablemente estas manifestaciones no
hubieran llegado a ninguna parte si no
hubiera sido por el joven Mohamed
Bouazizi, un frutero de 26 años que se
quemó a lo bonzo después de que la
policía confiscara su negocio de venta
ambulante.
Así es como se inició lo que los
periodistas llamaron la Revolución de
los Jazmines. De repente, todas las
ciudades tunecinas se llenaron de
manifestantes y a diferencia de otros
dictadores Abidine Ben Alí no opuso la
más mínima resistencia.
"Ben Alí se retira tras 23 años en el poder y
abandona Túnez". A partir de este momento
el presidente del parlamento formó un
gobierno provisional y liberó a más de
500 presos políticos. No sólo eso
además todos los disidentes tunecinos
que estaban repartidos por el extranjero
regresaron al país entre otros
este señor que vemos aquí que se
llamaba Moncef Marzouki que por aquel
entonces era el presidente de la
comisión árabe de los derechos humanos.
"La pregunta que se estarán haciendo es si
en Túnez
estamos hablando sobre islamismo. La
respuesta es no.
En túnez estamos hablando sobre
democracia".
Fonseca: tan sólo un año después de
que Bouzazi fin se prendiera fuego
Túnez estaba celebrando sus primeras
elecciones libres y así es como nuestro
amigo Marzouki se convierte en el
presidente del país. El problema que el
primer ministro es del partido islamista.
Hablamos del llamado movimiento Ennahda
que es algo así como la versión
tunecina de los Hermanos Musulmanes,
aunque un poquito más moderada. En un
momento en el que se acababan de
legalizar más de 100 partidos
políticos, Ennahda era el único
movimiento bien estructurado y con unos
líderes claros. Y por eso este partido
ganó la mayoría de los escaños del
parlamento. Y no olvidéis que este
parlamento era el que tenía la misión
de redactar la nueva constitución
tunecina.
Por cierto que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es No Respect, una banda de nu
metal de Lima en Perú que nos ha
mandado su música.
Si os gusta encontraréis más enlaces
de ellos en la descripción.
Y os preguntaréis, ¿con este panorama
cómo es posible que la constitución de
Túnez sea laica?
Lo cierto es que en este momento de
tanta incertidumbre política, los
sectores islamistas más radicales formaron
lo que llamaron las ligas
islámicas, que por supuesto estaban
apoyadas por el primer ministro que
quería islamizar es país a marchas
forzadas.
Esto significaba vandalismo en las
calles mucha violencia y lo que es peor:
"los líderes de la oposición Mohamed Brahmi
y Chokri Belaid, asesinados con
la misma pistola".
Mientras tanto los ingresos del turismo
en este país caían en picado.
Lógicamente nadie quiere viajar de
vacaciones a un sitio tan peligroso y
eso generó aún más malestar social.
Ante este panorama el resto de partidos
políticos laicos formaron un frente
común contra Ennahda y su primer ministro.
Y así es cómo a este bloque islamista no le queda más
remedio que aceptar en su gabinete de
ministros a otros políticos de otros
partidos. Y esto significa que en
poquitos meses tanto las ligas
islámicas como los Hermanos Musulmanes
en Egipto pasan a ser considerados como
grupos terroristas.
Lógicamente los islamistas más
radicales abandonaron el gobierno en
este momento y poco más tarde lo
harían los demás miembros islamistas
más moderados que dejaron todo el poder
de decisión a los partidos más laicos
a cambio solamente de una cosa y es que
reconocieran en la nueva construcción
al islam como religión oficial.
El resultado, que la nueva constitución
tunecina no sólo reconoce la libertad
de expresión sino también la libertad
de culto.
No sólo eso también garantiza una
educación imparcial no religiosa y sí,
el islam mantiene un estatus totalmente
simbólico pero el país se rige por
leyes totalmente laicas y así es como
surgen nuevos periódicos y una sociedad
civil muchísimo más fuerte que en
cualquier otro país del norte de
África. Y por eso cuando se convocan
elecciones de nuevo en el año 2014
los islamistas pierden frente a este
frente que habían formado todos los
partidos laicos y liberales que se
llamaba Nida Tounes.
Para que os deis cuenta de la influencia que juega el
turismo en la sociedad tunecina
mirad este mapa con los resultados
electorales de los últimos comicios. Si
os fijáis los islamistas pierden en
todas las zonas de playa que es donde
están los hoteles y donde está la gente
que se dedica al turismo.
Sin embargo ganan en las regiones más
rurales que es donde todavía el turismo
no tiene esa influencia. Pero esperad un
momento porque las cosas no son tan
bonitas como nos gustarían.
Tan sólo unos meses después de que
Túnez apruebe su nueva constitución,
el DAESH -o el Estado Islámico- organiza un
atentado en el Museo del Bardo que es
una de las principales atracciones
turísticas de este país.
A este país le siguen otros dos
atentados en total 73 muertos.
Pero no sólo eso.
Como resultado el número de
turistas británicos que solía batir
récords en los primeros meses del año
ha caído en un 93,2%".
Así que el nuevo gobierno de Túnez no sólo
tiene que lidiar con problemas de
seguridad sino también con una crisis
económica que está destruyendo la
principal industria del país y por eso
noticias como ésta son tan importante
"Túnez ofrece a los inversores extranjeros proyectos
por valor de 50.000 millones de dólares".
No sólo eso, la Unión Europea ha
eliminado los aranceles que había a la
importación de aceite de oliva tunecino.
Ya sabéis que en la Unión Europea
la agricultura está protegida del
extranjero con muchísimas impuestos.
Pero en el caso de Túnez es crucial
apoyar la industria del olivo que como
hemos visto es la segunda más
importante de todo el país. Pero esperad
un momento porque ya os podéis
imaginar cuál es la respuesta de los
agricultores europeos especialmente los
italianos.
"Salvemos nuestra excelencia, no al aceite
tunecino".
Esto es especialmente gracioso si
tenemos en cuenta que buena parte de ese
aceite "made in Italy" en realidad está
hecho en túnez y después en etiquetado
en Italia.
Y aquí es donde empieza la batalla
política en Europa porque por un lado
es crucial rescatar la economía
tunecina para que puedan mantener su
democracia pero por el otro
muchas empresas europeas no están
dispuestas a perder sus privilegios.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿creéis que la Unión
Europea tiene que abrir su mercado con
Túnez para que puedan mantener su
democracia? Y por otro lado, ¿creéis que
Túnez puede llegar a convertirse en un
modelo para sus países vecinos?
Podéis dejarme vuestras respuestas en
los comentarios y no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos salgan al para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones como siempre si alguien
quiere profundizar más en este tema
encontrará varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo.